I did not hit her it's not true it's
bullshit I did not hit her I did not
[Music]
welcome back to my pre-1970 series that
I've been doing all year every single
month and I thought it was time to
switch it up a little bit and talk about
a film that is great in a different way
and that film is plan 9 from outer space
directed by the famed Edie
Wood released in 1959 officially this
film went into relative obscurity until
film critic Michael Medved and his
brother wrote a book about the golden
turkeys films they considered the worst
of all time and they named this film
than number one it played on late-night
television for years and finally reached
superior cult status when Tim Burton
made the film atwood starring Johnny
Depp which explored that directors home
life and his work life and now it's
pretty much one of the best worst movies
ever made and if you've ever seen it you
can understand why because Ed Wood was
really the original Tommy Wise oh one
thing sure Spectre Clay's dead murdered
and somebody's responsible both of them
proved to be fairly inept when it came
to actually crafting a good film but
their Drive and their passion was so
intense that they got their films made
but what you can say about wise oh and
the room is that he planned a film that
he could actually make with the money he
had he didn't try to make a science
fiction epic Ed Wood he tried to make
films that he didn't have the budget to
make but he made them anyway because
passion you got to do it you know this
film is about aliens that have come to
earth because humanity is gonna destroy
itself we've created technology that's
just too destructive and we are the
danger and the aliens are here to let us
know that that's the case and in so
doing they want to raise the dead have
Bela Lugosi involved in some way shape
or form
act like a vampire and an undead zombie
walking around because that's how they
prove their message I guess but this
film opens with an announcer of sorts
who is actually a psychic who had a show
back in the day that Ed Wood was a fan
of and he's setting up the film for us
and he's clearly reading from a cue card
his eyes are actually moving from left
to right it's the most apparent
teleprompter /qk
I've ever seen in a feature film and
that's our first hint at just how
oblivious Ed Wood was to the technical
presentation of a film in particular the
sets don't even get me started on the
sets they look like they were made with
construction paper and Elmer's glue an
early scene with the two pilots in their
apparent airplane despite sitting on
household furniture shows a UFO passed
by you can see the reflection of the
boom mic as well as the script sitting
in the pilot's lap this is what I watch
these movies for moments like that
little nuggets like that that being said
I have to give credit where credit's due
apparently this film was originally
meant to be broadcast in the 185 aspect
ratio the widescreen aspect ratio and
most DVD transfers of this movie have it
in four by three full screen so the
common excuse for this is that certain
things were meant to be cropped out of
the image that Ed would never expected
to be seen and that's why you can see
the script in his lap or the boom mic
but I'm going to guess that the director
who made sets out of construction paper
I I know it's actually like wood but it
still looks like a paper mache arts and
crafts set from elementary school I'm
just gonna assume that the man who made
that film probably didn't really care
about the script being in the person's
lap I'm not gonna make any excuses for
him something else this film commonly
does is things that might appear more
expensive or perhaps violent or could be
considered difficult to accomplish often
occur off screen mostly people screaming
and dying like this scene
[Music]
and this scene which is easily my
biggest laugh in the entire film
confused by his great loss the old man
left that home never to return again
[Music]
apparently he just walked off screen and
got smashed by a car right after
attending his wife's funeral this guy is
very unlucky so bela lugosi is in this
film briefly because he was actually
becoming good friends with Ed Wood and
this was his last credited film before
his death this footage was going to be
for another project that Ed Wood was
working on but he decided to use that
footage and incorporate it into this
film to make it be Bela Lugosi's last
film to draw in other actors and
potential funds for the movie at the
same time though he used a stunt double
to complete Bela Lugosi's performance
and it's just a guy walking around
holding his cape to his face
you can't pick this shit up man you just
can't it's one of the reasons the film
does have an odd kind of obscure charm
to it because despite how terrible it
really is you have to give it to the guy
for completing his film and getting it
released now the dialogue in plan 9 is a
thing to behold but particularly the
editing of conversations quite often a
scene will cut to a shot that is
actually from the same set up and so it
just looks like a jump cut it's truly
awful and there are so many moments like
that in particular these moments pretty
dark out there once you get beyond the
range of those lights you won't be able
to see your hand in front of your face
I'll be getting one up last night from
the patrol car be careful please I'm a
big boy and not Johnny
don't forget that Tornai Tian and the
scratch beat yeah I hadn't thought of
that
we're greeted with editing like this
throughout the entire picture there are
so many sequences that cut into other
shots that just don't meld and you just
have to imagine ed woods standing behind
that camera thinking about how much he
wants this film to be completed and not
caring so much about the actual quality
he just wants to get that shot and he
apparently edited the film as well
himself and so you can also see him in
the editing room like piecing it
together and it's like I said there's a
charm to it but it's purely from a cult
perspective like you can watch the film
with friends and enjoy yourself but it's
pretty awful something else that seems
mixed up amongst the dialogue is the way
people described the UFOs that appear in
the film like the pilot calling it a
cigar I saw a flying saucer saucer you
mean the kind from up there yeah it's
kind of part it was shaped like a huge
cigar that looks nothing like a cigar
actually but you know whatever ed Wood
apparently bought an actual model kit
for UFOs and used those for the special
effects speaking of special effects this
film contains one of the most monotonous
scenes of UFOs versus the military I've
ever seen it goes on and on it never
ends
[Music]
and during this insanely long sequence
we have this man who is obviously
standing in front of the sky that's the
backdrop to sky that's that's a real sky
it's not a like a wall like with it
cleared paint on it so we finally get a
look at the aliens in the film and of
course they look like human beings
wearing some cheap costume store outfits
and the way they greet each other is
they sort of slapped their shoulders
when they say hello but this guy looks
like he had just done it a hundred times
and he just wants to go home because
he's drunk as hell and he's just done
with this shooting day he doesn't want
to be there your space commander has
returned from Earth
so now kingpin I mean the Living Dead
and the vampire woman as well as the
stunt double are on the scene and
they're walking so slowly I mean half
the speed of Michael Myers to the point
of lethargy this film can get very
boring and extremely repetitive there
are sequences that are hilarious and
very strangely watchable they're sort of
a perverse dreamlike trance that this
film can put you in because it's just so
bad and you just kind of sit back like
in awe similar to the room but there's a
lot of parts to the film where you just
want to go to bed but the film picks up
quickly because there's one cop in
particular who's very frightened and he
doesn't want to go near any of these
supposedly mning dead and or alien sites
he doesn't want to go near these
locations yeah we shouldn't investigate
any further without the permission of
next akin let's go get it oh I see what
you mean the gravestones down there well
let's go down and find out whose grave
it is how by going down and finding out
are you sure you mean that lieutenant if
I didn't mean it I wouldn't have said it
scared well what do I get hooked up with
these spook details monsters graves
bodies and what continuously saves the
film for me is I'm just gonna clone
kingpin because this face that he wears
as he walks around is just priceless it
really looks like there should be sounds
coming out of it
[Music]
[Applause]
if I'm being completely honest it's
actually kind of hard to follow the film
because the story doesn't really make
any sense it's just a bunch of sequences
that feel like Ed Wood wanted to make a
horror scene here he wanted a scene with
a vampire lady making a weird face or
something with Bela Lugosi he just
wanted to make a movie really bad but he
wasn't as concerned with making a
narrative that that made sense so that
felt like it flowed so we finally get to
the main message of the film where the
pilot and some other guys are on board
this alien spacecraft and the aliens
just unload with all of this story
telling about how humanity's destroying
itself and we're all gonna blow up
because we're eventually gonna create
this bomb in the future that's gonna
destroy everything and I guess by
raising the dead and this vampire lady
and Bela Lugosi stunt-double they
somehow we're trying to communicate this
to us which makes no real sense really
at all I mean it makes no sense but it's
damn entertaining that's for sure
well I assure you no harm has come to
her would you like to see next time you
try that I won't aim at the board you're
a headstrong young man soon one of the
worst fights I've ever seen happens most
of it is obscured by smoke and one
unbroken wide shot where you can't see
anything it's just you hear scuffling
noises and loud music and there's smoke
and their ship blows up and the humans
are back on earth and they're just
talking about how man it was interesting
with those aliens but really the one
thing about the film that is probably
the best in regards to just how
hilarious it is is the narration the
opening announcer continues to narrate
the entire film he says my friends like
a billion times the things he says it's
just blatant explaining of everything
that's on screen it's like it's a story
being told to a young child it's
definitely the best part of the film
rockets
we're quickly set up Colonel Tom Edwards
in
charge of saucer field activities was to
make the greatest decision of his career
he made that decision Colonel Edwards
gave the signal to fire but overall this
film has a cult status for a reason you
have to give it to Ed Wood for making it
for getting out there and doing it he
accomplished more than like 90% of
hopeful filmmakers he actually went out
goddess film made and had it distributed
despite how terrible it is he worked on
it and he got it made
[Music]
there's a lot of great movies I want to
talk about for the rest of the year but
I do need to talk about some films like
this too because it's just fun and and
there's tons of older films that are
actually kind of hard to get through
like this is one of the ones where you
can watch it and have fun a really
terrible movie from like 1940 that isn't
even entertaining like this that's tough
to watch this however it has something
to it there's a quality to it you can't
really replicate guys thank you so much
as always for watching please continue
to watch more reviews which will be
coming to you very soon as always if you
like this you can click right here and
get stubborn eyes
[Music]
you